many people say that you have to attract
your audience in the first 15 seconds of
a video well I'm just gonna completely
disregard that and be very blunt right
here this video I didn't really get much
done in this time-lapse I suppose let's
just say that I wasn't completely on my
a-game while recording this stream I was
just there were things and I wasn't
completely capable of playing this game
alright but you know in the end I did I
suppose get some decent work done with
this was obviously quite important to
have that photos done finished on the
side of the train station but also get
foliage on the side of that rock so I
could sort of move on that was a bit of
a mental thing like really if I didn't
put that foliage over there the park
would look so much more unfinished and I
really would have felt like it was I
wasn't be I wasn't able to justify
already working on the touch area so
this is gonna help connect that a tiny
bit more already though other than this
part with which goes like beyond the
rocks I just couldn't stop like placing
small flowers and shrubs over there so
eventually that just turned into a fairy
tale for us at least yeah I literally
sat that on the stream I was like
laughing and saying oh this is turning
into a fairy tale forest and then Vicky
came with the idea to put mushrooms in
there to make it look like a real fairy
tale for us so that for some reason I
went with that idea as well so now we
have a real fairy tale forest behind
that I suppose it is sort of cool though
I really didn't want to get too much in
there since you know I don't have a
efteling sort of theme well I can just
put any random thing in there and
justify it for reasons of ah its fantasy
since you know I do have to sort of
stick to the country over here and
unicorns don't exist in Spain so that's
not gonna fit with the entire Spanish
sort of theme but doesn't where aren't
there mushrooms like not counting and
Arctica in the North Pole I think there
are like mushrooms pretty much all over
the globe that that should be alright
does that fake mushrooms you can place
fake mushrooms I'm really aggressing
over here yeah this was the the the the
flower placement the flower placement I
have a speech impediment I'm very sorry
actually don't and buy that joke too but
yeah that was just I don't know it just
find it way too much fun to place
flowers I I can't stop and a level which
you should stop at because realistically
speaking there really is a limit to
placing flowers and I have probably
hinted at this before but I still see
this I still see so many people do this
when they like get it planted that's the
size of 15 [ __ ] football fields and
they put it full of all kinds of
different flowers from all over the
world you can't just do that you really
have to keep your amount of flowers in
your park to a respectable man because
people like some handyman are gonna
maintain and we're gonna have to
maintain a whatever that's it and that's
not fun if you've got enormous planter
is not to mention that they don't just
have to be able to maintain it they have
to be able of course to actually reach
it so having planters underneath your
coaster in the middle of nowhere with
flowers in them is definitely a no-go
which is why I did reluctantly place the
flowers over there figuring yeah you can
actually like past the opening times get
some handyman in there I'm calling him a
handyman but have workers of the park I
suppose they have an identity too they
have a name too I I don't have any at
the moment but when I do get some I'll
make sure to give them cool names but
those whoever they're called how
supposed to be able to go there so
that's also a thing to keep in mind so
never make your flower boxes planters
whatever you will put more fields too
large and never put too many flowers in
them so that's and if you kind of stick
to that rule you should be alright also
though I would also recommend is sort of
like this not stick not going with too
many colors at once like you don't just
place every single color in the kalos
spectrum a flower is like on one little
spot I always like to either do it in
y'all just kind of put some variations
in there but not all the colors in one
spot and if you do use many colors use
them in patterns is what I would usually
say but yeah that was about that that's
also where the the mushrooms who were
featured at that point also at that
point I figured that I needed some more
rock work
over here the only problem is that I
have no idea what I still have no idea
what I'm even gonna do with this log
flume like overall it still has a bit of
a real Lake itch thing which is which
has all to do with the fact that I did
have to make all the tracks at the same
height which is a bit of a problem
because if I didn't do that then I would
get the cello water and that would be
absolutely terrible I really want nuts
so that's why I kind of made me lay out
like that but making me lay out like
that isn't too much of a problem for a
log flume technically but it's really
hard to actually see a good scenery to
it if there's no different sort of
levels of heights so that's a bit of a
problem I might at some point if I find
them because at the moment I lost them
no idea where they are anymore but there
are some log flume because some scenery
pieces with terrain pieces that like
surround the log flume tracks and I
should also be able to get those in with
ECT hopefully if that's not gonna work
then I'm probably gonna cry but
hopefully I should be able to get some
more grass and as soon as you have of
course more ground you can place more
stuff like random pillows random boxes
and things like that
which I know it's it's very just random
but there's not much else that I can
really do over there and of course the
little fountains at all interactivity
little interactive things that's always
nice for a water ride oh and at this
point I figured my um my little stupid
mind at the time figured that out at
little details to the Maestri ejaculate
wasn't that bad of an idea I did got
some pretty interesting things about
there I was just looking at the Main
Street I'm figuring that overall it
looks alright but it just could use some
tiny details here and there because I'm
accustomed scenery hipster and I wanted
to kind of add some more variation to
the existing pieces because you were you
could really recognize the pieces like
that was clearly the wainscot from the
Alpine set you can see the alpine
village six beams so just sort of
covering things up with other custom
scenery and adding stuff to it this
makes it look a tiny bit more original
and less recognizable which is not
something that at least for me it it's a
bit annoying to really recognize all of
the accustomed Syria and I do know that
not
everybody as a walk in customs in your
dictionary but it's still a bit it's a
bit of a turn-off for me when you really
recognize some pieces and recognize the
exact way in which echo subsidiaries sat
is used not just necessarily because
it's something that you've seen so many
times before but also because you're
really using something what it's made
for and although it sounds like you
should me you should use something for
what it's made for I really just like
also seeing people use pieces for the
things that they're not made for and
actually do some creative stuff with
them so that's also what I was trying to
force myself to but I wasn't I wasn't
even so good at it at the moment though
especially with these little wooden
details and that is definitely something
that I can probably throw out there you
can pretty much just stack them for all
you can and get brilliant interesting
combinations there are so many piece
there are so many sets out there with
different wooden pieces and I'm talking
about pretty much anything be it Wayne
Scots or cornices or beams that you can
just put on top of each other and get
some really interesting sort of
combinations with that I mean the bottom
of that little blue building which you
just saw but now don't see anymore was
comprised I think of the wainscot of the
alpine village sets and the corners from
sergey's things days you can see it
right now in the top left corner and now
it's gone bottom right ok I can't I
can't keep that up but yeah that was a
that was still pretty cool I've no idea
why I was even trying to keep it up and
yeah the thing was I went into this
entire stream figuring right let's build
Amsterdam and then I completely forgot
what I was going to do I don't even
think I had much of a plan at the time
and it just ripped it just didn't work
out I tried a couple of things remove
them remove the videos and just figured
oh bugger let's let's keep going let's
do some other stuff and just do that
actually get some work done and that's
why I figured I would maybe finally
tackle the Maestri because at this point
the Main Street is sort of finished but
it really still needs the signs of life
which I've talked about in the last
episode but though I didn't get any
signs I could place more planters add
some more foliage because foliage
makes things look alive if you've ever
got any sort of facade that looks very
dead just add values to it it's so
important and at that point I had the
ingenious idea to place that traveler
over that I'm not even sure if I really
want to keep it but like the idea was
hey it's a it's a traveling man and he
like starts at the beginning of the Main
Street and then look straight ahead at
the compass which is in the main square
and from that area you can basically
travel like entire Eurasia maybe it's
like a Marco Polo I mean I got no idea
it was just a bit of a weird idea I
don't even know when I was going on
about at that time can't even remember
to be very honest sort of I suppose that
that was the basic idea but how I even
came to that I've no idea but yeah that
that happened over there it's the
traveling man I suppose I can keep it I
mean it is a good filler of space and
fillers of spaces are quite important
sometimes and this corner was really
looking for a use like something in that
case I can see that I'm running out of
time so I think the time to say goodbye
has come so thank you guys for watching
and I'll see you guys later every design